welcome back to round six of my dubai
rapid tournament if you watched up until
now you'll know i'm five out of six
in round five i did lose to a grand
master
round six marked day two of the event
there were nine rounds total
and in this round i'm playing a player
by the name of cedrani
and i do have a photo from right before
the game
i was wearing my onomai queen t-shirt
credit to irene sukundar good friend of
mine who took this photo
and my shirt actually foreshadowed what
was going to end up happening in the
game
now i don't want to spoil too much
beyond that
but we did have an exciting round six
game
so let's get into it
i was white and if you've been following
the recaps closely
you'll know in round two with the white
pieces i played the english opening
in round four i went for the ortho
schnapp gambit with e4 so i decided to
keep mixing things up and in this game i
went for my bread and butter
london system opening
d4 and bishop f4
and the reason why i went for this is
because i did a little bit of
preparation for my opponent
and i saw he plays a line combining c5
and bishop f5
which is known to be somewhat dubious
and the move where we went into is c5 e3
knight c6 knight f3 and bishop f5 and i
do get the question a decent amount from
viewers
what to do in the london when the
opponent tries to copy you and puts her
bishop on f5 and my general answer is to
go for the early c4 and queen b3
but that actually applies more to the
position if black plays bishop f5 right
away
then you can play e3 and go for the plan
of c4 queen b3 to pressure the
undefended pawn on b7 combine that with
this and this
it's very stable development for whites
what we had in our game was a bit
different because black committed a pawn
to c5
and here there's actually another idea
which turns out to be really nice for
white
is simply to take the pawn on c5
and after pawn e6 to play the move
knight d4
now this wouldn't exist if i didn't have
the chance to take on c5 but after
knight d4 black's under a lot of
pressure because not only is the bishop
attacked but there's ideas of pressuring
the knight on c6
with with bishop e5
so for example if the bishop just
retreats here
i can pin the knight
attacking twice and if rook c8 i can
take on c6
take and play bishop a6
and this is actually a pretty common
opening trap
i've had a good number of times online
and white is winning the rook by force
here if rookie 8
i completely dominate all the background
squares with my bishops and white is
winning at least exchange
so
okay so i was just editing that and
realized i made a crucial mistake if
knight takes c6 and bishop a6
it's black to move and trap white
so good job to those who found the move
queen a5 check
uh picking up the bishop on e6
i confused myself and uh here's me
trying to correct my mistake
i will say though after bishop g6 the
best move for white is still to play
bishop e5 and after rook c8
uh played b4 holding onto the pawn
stockfish gives like plus almost three
for white in this position so it's still
good for white uh but let's get back to
the game
so going back
my opponent didn't play bishop g6
but rather took on c5
which turns out to be the best move
if knight takes d4 i would have taken
back and held on to the c5 pawn
so after bishop z5
i'm not winning any material
but i do get a really nice position
after the training f5 i get the bishop
hair black's pawn structure is a bit
more weak with the double f pawns and
iso d-pawn
and from here i continued development
played bishop d3
knight d7 c3
castling
knight d2 and i was feeling pretty
comfortable here but as we're going to
see things turned out not to be so
simple
and my opponent grabbed initiative
for the next couple moves starting with
knight g6
hitting my bishop
i did not want to
grab the pawn here because not only
would i
give back the bishop pair
but i would allow queen b6 hitting these
pawns black would be winning back upon
not to mention black could also throw in
rookie 8 followed by queen b6 this is
not the position i would want to enter
so instead of taking an f5 i just
dropped the bishop back to g3
and here my opponent played a move
which i thought was a mistake in the
moment but after analyzing the game i'm
realizing this is probably one of the
strongest moves
in the position
is to play f4
sacrificing upon
and trying to take advantage of the fact
that i have not yet castled and black
can forcibly open the e-file
before i get castled
so i did go ahead and take
and after rookie 8
i have a somewhat unpleasant decision to
make
i either have to play king f1 and lose
casting rights or if i play bishop e2
i'm subjecting myself to a lot of pain
but i could start with queen e7
tying down my king and queen to
defending the bishop
and then d4 is coming and this would be
really unpleasant for whites
so instead i did choose to put my king
on f1
and
even though i lost casting rights i do
have a pawn i do have the bishop hair i
was still feeling pretty good about the
position
uh game continued from here queen f6
queen f3
bishop d6
and here i made the decision to
trade on g6
uh just because there's not a great way
to defend the pawn if i advance it to f5
there's knight e5
and bishop g6 was a way of removing one
of the attackers against f4
my opponent took back
and here i play the move which
i knew i was probably going to play
eventually
is pawn h4
uh given that i
have not castled my king is stuck on f1
my rook needs a way of trying to find a
purpose in life
and pawn h4
creates idea of eventually playing h5
opening the h file
and the long term idea is to get the
queen to the h file and checkmate on h8
so i was feeling optimistic but my
opponent played a series of relatively
good moves
starting with knight e7
i go ahead play h5 and now knight f5 so
very nice square of the knight hits the
bishop also prevents bishop h4 which is
one of the ideas with bringing the pawn
to h5
and here i decide to play queen g4
trying to shift the queen over to each
file
i do have ideas of queen h3 eventually
taking and mating
but of course that's a little bit slow
and black starts trying to deliver the
first punches
takes on g3
i take back with pawn
and now plays a really interesting move
on g5
which is another pawn sacrifice
but the idea is to prevent the h file
from opening uh keeping my pawn on h5
and after i take with queen
i thought there was a small possibility
i could end up getting quadruple pawns
actually two moves away from uh from
getting it in this position if my
opponent were to take take g6 take
this would have been a funny line along
the g file
but
of course my opponent doesn't want to
trade queens in this position
because my king is so exposed
on f1 it's the black's benefit to keep
queens on the board
opponent plays queen e6
creating the battery a long e file now
has some threat of queen e2
and here instead of trying to defend
against the threat i went for a counter
attack with a move pawn h6 and even
though this looks a little bit scary
because i allow queen e2
after king g1
black is actually the one who should be
scared here
has no time to take the knight because i
deliver mates
and uh really not easy to defend bishop
c5 doesn't do any damage i just play
king h2
and if g6 my queen can come in
and this might even be mating by force
if we see bishop f8
there is a really nice line here h7 king
h7 queen f7 bishop g7 and now the deadly
king retreating to g1
unleashing the rook
not quite mate because there's queen h5
but i would win the queen and go on to
win the game here so when i played the
pawn h6
i did have these sort of ideas swirling
in my mind with uh mating attack
combining the queen pawn and rook
but my opponent
very quickly played pawn g6
and we can actually see based on the
timestamps that
my point gained time after playing g6
there was a five-second increment
so black's defending against mate and
again putting the question how i'm going
to deal with queen e2
i decided to play knight f3
trying to bring in another attacker and
again i'm not scared of this because my
king can run to safety
so my opponent starts with
a strong move here bishop to c5
which turns out to be really strong
because not only
does it cover f2 and g1 so now my king
has no legal moves it threatens made in
one with queen e2
and it has another kind of hidden threat
to it
which i almost missed during the game
and i'm a little bit embarrassed to
admit but during the game
i reached out my hand
about to touch my rook
ready to play rookie one which was kind
of the original move in my calculation
from before my opponent played bishop c5
but before i touched my rook i realized
rookie one
gets mated by force
so i encourage viewers to find the
response for black
black to move
force mate made in three
move would be queen a6
and this is why board vision is very
very important
especially in rapid chess where
you have to see things pretty quickly
queen a6 would just demolish me
along the diagonal i have no choice but
to play either c4 and rookie 2
and eventually get mated so thankfully i
realized that before it was too late
and instead of getting mated i found the
move knight to e5
it turns out i had an even better option
to play h7
provoke the king to one of these squares
and then just force a queen trade and
this would have been just an easier way
to to simplify
and steer the game
into an end game where i would have two
extra pawns
even if i lose a pawn
i'm ready to start targeting d5 and
there would be excellent winning chances
for white here
but queen stared on the board
position stayed spicy
i played knight e5
here my opponent played king h7 great
move blockading the pawn preventing my
rook from enjoying
a full h-file
and i play rookie one getting my last
piece involved
opponent plays queen a6 check i block
with a rook
and now i should note that the pawn on
e2 cannot be captured this would just
walk into queen f6
and there's just too many mating threats
for black to deal with there would be
one more check but after rookie one
there's no more good checks and white is
winning here
so instead my opponent played a
defensive move bishop to e7
uh attacking the queen
forcing me to retreat
and then put the bishop on f6
so
now black has a bit more stable setup on
the king side my rook is pinned along
the diagonal
and here i went for a very double edged
move
knight takes off seven
winning a pawn
but at the same time allowing the rook
to have scope
against my pinned rook on e2
now my rook is sufficiently defended
but here my opponent found a really nice
move rook to e4 planting the rook on a
really nice central square aligning with
the queen and preparing the double up
on the file
and this is where things begin to get
really really tricky
time was also getting very low for both
of us we were both under three minutes
and i went ahead and played king f2
unpinning my rook and trying to trade on
e4
but my opponent did not give me any time
to trade throws in queen to b6 check
king e1
and played rook to e8 so creating the
battery along the e-file
and here we reach a really really
critical moment
where i played my next move
way too quickly
uh during the game i had calculated this
position
and thought i have a really nice move
knight e5 which i played really quickly
we can see based on timestamp um i i
gained time after playing this move
i thought it was being very clever
uh blocking the rooks from
creating the battery against e2
also targeting the g6 pawn
thought this was very nicely
multi-purpose
also opening up queen d7 check
unfortunately 95
fails terribly to black's next move
and my opponent found the next move
relatively easily
rook takes e5
and i hear i realized
oh no
my f pawn is pinned to the queen
and i have all the same problems which
existed in the previous position
now if we go back
the move i had to play
was rook takes e4
and this would have been really
difficult for me to play because it
allows rook takes e4
king d1
and then black is having all the fun
here queen xb2 it looks like i'm getting
mated
however the engine does find an escape
uh knight e5
and turns out there's no mate here and i
have enough counter play
not to lose a game
um unfortunately i didn't find this line
under 95 opponent took
and this is where i used most of my
remaining time
to try and find a way to
survive and after
about two minutes of thinking here
i played the move
on takes rook
and quietly said to myself
oh no my queen
this isn't the trappy oh no my queen
that we all know and love
this is just
sadly watching my queen
vanish from the board
and i went for this line because i
thought okay maybe there's some
potential with the two connect past
pawns some idea of rookie seven
and black still has to be careful
but unfortunately f6 pawn also falls off
the board and now black is just
basically up a queen for a rook
played on a few more moves tried to
defend against
all of black's annoying threats d4 was a
very nice move just opening up more
lines in the position
making way for the queen
uh forcing a trait of pawns
we trade on c3 and after queen to a2
king d3 queen f2
if i take the rook here i
walk into queen g2
and black would just win my final rook
so instead i resign the game
the dgt board actually shows i played
the move king d4 here
because when i resigned we put the kings
on the dark squares to signify black
winds it's just one of the quirks with
the dgt board
uh but king d4 it's kind of a nice
self-destructive
image for the final position
and uh and yeah i got upset in in this
round um emotionally i wasn't too upset
my opponent fought back
from uh what i thought was a pretty good
opening for me
and i just had to move on and
play my best chess going forward so
there are still three more rounds to go
next video i'll recap round seven
and i don't want to give away too much
but round seven
does feature another attempted staffer
gambit so stay tuned and as always if
you have questions
leave them in the comments below
and i'll see you in the next video